we write it we ready for the time
unfortunately my mustache didn't but I
am very glad to see the back that the
before and after picture it's just like
I've lost ten years and age and about
five levels of creepiness and I know
some people in the comment section seem
to like it but oh no I am very glad that
it's gone now I apologize in this video
is a day late the reason for that is
that yesterday I should clarify I'm
helping out with interviews at the
moment so I'm doing couple of hours of
shame people around children's area
showing two into each other and I'd
allocated some time to film this and I
sat down I talked to the cameras about
20 minutes about what's been going on
got up to check the footage and turns
out I didn't turn the camera on
so that was slightly disheartening but
I'm doing this now
so eighth week I handed in on my work I
only had two classes and a couple of
lectures to go to you and then term was
finished and as a consequence eight
weeks pretty relaxed by comparison to us
the other weeks and you feel like you're
winding down towards the summer vacation
which obviously is very nice the same
time it's very busy because an awful lot
of things happen so on Monday I had my
hands concert we played a concert in
Merton Chapel including saw some John
Williams was a whole mixer stuff for a
wind band so we play a mix of a more
contemporary music it's and classical
music
and that was great it was good fun doing
actually then on Tuesday I went to a
friend's concert who is in a string
quintet yes a string quintet who gave a
performance at Corpus Christi College
and they did amongst other things
father's not just the Adagio for Strings
but other movements that you don't
normally hear which was great on
Wednesday I had the college pantone
which like I mentioned before I'm in and
we were rehearsing this for a couple
days beforehand which was really good
fun people really seemed to enjoy it not
least because of custard Pines
well on Thursday we had the Bob where
the last pot of the year which is the
Christmas theme Bob and loads of people
came back from my you've already
graduated to enjoy that and when we went
out afterwards which is really fun and I
had sort of had a good like that for a
very long time because just cause of
work so it was nice to really let your
hair down and then on Friday
everything was wrapping up and I
attended a LAN party or attempted to be
tempted to do a LAN party of flame Team
Fortress 2 over one of the accommodation
blocks except we kick anything to hug so
we just went to the bar Friday was drink
the bar dry night so in some Peters bar
normally the prices are very low because
we're the best bar in Oxford so you know
pints one pound sixty or so two pounds
or something more expensive ice Abigail
and I'm by day night drink the VAR tribe
and that everything was a pound so Sam
again was half price then halfway
through the night they realized I think
was an hour before closing time
they wants to get rid of a more big more
of the stuff so they set everything to
50 P for pie which was fun but it was a
night again it was a nice way to really
round off the term you know you finished
all if you work you can have a couple of
days just to recover and sleep and
particularly for freshers so this is the
first just juices are the first time
knocks food that you've really gone all
out and they are absolutely exhausted so
they've come back home and are
presumably still sleeping now a couple
of days after Tom's finished but in
addition to all that fun stuff here I
had two classes to go see one theory one
front one promised ferret physics the
standard loaded lectures and I also went
to a colloquium at the physics
department now a cloakroom is a guest
speaker
that's invited him to talk about some
relevant topic now the guy he was
talking this time round it was an Emer
Isis a Marissa stammer Isis memorizes
professor Alex but buckle Frank close
and he was talking about the Higgs boson
and obviously that's very relevant at
the moment because it's sort of the
biggest bit of physics has happened this
year and it was very very interesting
talking it so tender
by luminaries of the department you know
you've got real topb can recognize all
of your lecturers you know really quite
famous people they're actually the
probably aren't famous outside of Oxford
but to me they're things he was
promoting his new book the infinity
puzzle and it the talk was absolutely
fascinating and I'm seriously
considering just buying the book because
the story of the Higgs boson being
postulated is not as straightforward as
people seem to think it is which is that
you know Peter Higgs just kind of came
up with it over one day have his
imagination it's not it's a lot more
involved in that it's a lot more
convoluted than that and there's a lot
more Nobel Prizes that are involved in
this story than I realized so I'm that's
saying to consider if you're thinking of
paying of Christmas present for somebody
who's interested in physics that I'm
sure it's gonna be a very very good book
but now tom is finished so I can breathe
a sigh of relief and everything is done
and when term is finished even though I
talk about having a great time in uni
talking about having a great time in uni
it is stood a relief one term finishes
because ultimately you are working
extremely hard the entire time here if
you're doing it right and so you turn
vidoes use the chance to catch up on
sleep
go back home and see your friends see
your family that kind of stuff that said
at the moment I am still in some pieces
because I'm helping with interviews so
during the interview period we've got
about a dozen people from all different
years all different subjects staying
behind to help so like I said before
showing people to their dreams both
where they can be staying for the night
and also their interview rooms staying
in the JCR if anybody has any questions
either about college life over the
university or you know what kind of
interviews is going to be kind of thing
so with the dogs bodies where you look
with the people who are here to help
maybe interview procedure is painless as
possible it's never going to be truly
painless but as painless as possible and
it's actually quite interesting talking
to applicants because I've realised
there's a five year age gap now between
me and people applying which is scary
but also hearing people's questions and
their and questions that you know the
answer to so trivially because you ask
them five years ago so on me because
stuff that I should have been covering
on this
so hopefully people they've been
watching these vlogs will be quite well
informed go into their interviews you
know what I'm just gonna check this
cameras on school as for the future of
this vlog there's been a bit of talk
about that in the comment section the
reason I was hesitant to continue this
next term which is the logical thing to
do was simply a question of time I was
intending to expand on the college
YouTube channel next term and that was
gonna be a huge project now because of
work and because of sort of looking at
my Master's project and thinking yeah if
I want to do this right I need to
dedicate my entire time to this I'm not
gonna be doing that plan anymore we're
gonna be adding new content to the
college YouTube channel but not quite in
that way that's saying it's gonna be a
little bit of a surprise but but that
has been informed by this vlogging
process but because I'm not doing that
anymore which because I'm not doing that
updates because YouTube channel as I
intended which would have been a very
time intensive project I feel that I can
justify carrying on with these now
whether I do or not depends on whether
my life remains interesting into next
term because it can't just be that do my
Master's project means that week after
week I'm just up sat in the lab doing
the same thing over and over again
writing code so if it would appear that
my life is germane worthy of being
logged about and were useful as an
insight into Oxford then I will continue
doing this next time doing one vlog a
week potentially one blog age of every
two weeks because there's not a huge
time commitment to do these folks but it
obviously is a bit of time taken out of
my Sundays in this case Monday but
having done this for a term I realize
now that there's so much that I've I've
yet to show you guys you know I haven't
shown you the bodily an average noonish
Marillion I haven't shown you so many
aspects of college life that to me or in
be so trivial that I'm probably gonna
throw in and without thinking about it
hopefully will be an insight you guys
including the room tour
- very awful about doing I have I
promised in the past to do the room -
and I haven't up till this point I'm
acting like a guilty child because I
know I said I'd do it so let's do it
so I live in the Paradise Street
accommodation block which is one of the
different addicts is owned by the
college but isn't on the million college
sight and slightly unfortunately I am in
room number 13 on the way into the room
you've got my notes board on your right
right on top of my radiator and large
piles of rubbish which I really should
move out and along from that you've got
my desk which has got large amounts of
class so at the moment I apologise
believe me I actually did do some
cleaning up before I film this so laptop
absolutely student essential different
files containing work and then most of
it's just crud then above that you've
got lots of storage on the shelves
including my reading for this term
released some of my reading between the
two was got my wall of stuff I like to
keep some mementos from certain things
and particularly film tickets and that
my certificate that says I went to that
conference in Germany
moving along for my desk yeah my music
stand bark is hard and then the bed
which everybody can see in the
background of my videos a small
associated pile of reading bedside table
then moving along you have my wardrobe
large amounts of storage above it
including an outrageous DVD collection
and then above that even more storage
which is occupied by my big suitcase and
then that's it for the most part of the
room then you just have my bathroom
which is pretty much what do you expect
the bathroom to be like you've got a
sink toilet and very nice shower and
that's pretty much it
how are you doing as for the interviews
fa q video
it's like Q&A video I will film in that
tomorrow I realized that you guys are
for a champion the bit to get this kind
of information because some of you will
be already doing interviews I would be
doing this today but with doing my
university work and the interview work I
actually haven't had that much time
today to vlog and edit so that is
something that I will be doing tomorrow
I promise that they will be going up my
channel because I know that for some of
you it is a very pressing need and yeah
if you have any last-minute questions
then please put them in the comment
section this video though by about three
o'clock tomorrow afternoon that will be
the cutoff
and then I'll start filling the video so
I've taken into everybody's question so
far and they will be answering them to
one and that will be go my channel
tomorrow evening
I I probably should say something to
little wrap up the whole project really
because this is it was designed to be an
experiment and access experiment I think
that it has been successful based on the
feedback that you guys in the giving me
and I really really do appreciate any
and all feedback whether that be good or
bad
in the comment section or in messages or
whatever it appears to be giving you
guys an insight into what it's actually
like to be an octopus student and that
was what I set up to do and that is why
I'd like to continue next time and if
that's not the case I'd like to hear why
any case that is the case I'd like to
hear about it so I I'm not just talking
to a camera robbing people on the
internet but it seems to have been a
success and I'm very glad that you guys
have taken some understanding away and
even some enjoyment away from these
blogs it's nice to sort of sum up my
experience is actually every week and I
put things in perspective it's been a
nice tool for me as well so I'd like to
thank you guys for spending the last
couple of weeks ëthey and if you are
having interviews now I wish you the
very very best of luck truly because
I've been in opposition I know what it's
like wish you the very best of luck with
your interviews and have a great
Christmas whether you have interviews a
lot and hopefully always seeing you in
not very long well my next term starts
on the 13th of January so you'll be
seeing me again sometime around then but
like I say until then best love with
interviews and have a Merry Christmas